my name is Kristen Lennox and I'm a
principal data scientist at beyond
limits my job is to help humans and
computers interact with each other in
industrial context today we're going to
be looking at some Hollywood depictions
of artificial intelligence and I'm gonna
be giving my view on how similar that is
to what's going on in the real world
today 2001 a Space Odyssey two
astronauts on a mission to Jupiter with
a computer in their ship supposedly the
most advanced artificially intelligent
computer that's ever been created good
afternoon how how's everything going
good afternoon mr. aymer everything is
going extremely well so how is is
described as working like a human brain
except a human brain that never makes
mistakes computers really don't work
like that
fundamentally computers don't think like
we think even when they're displaying
what appears to be emotion I'm afraid
it's trying to make you more comfortable
but it's not reflecting what's going on
under the hood what artificial
intelligence does is more task-specific
so we teach a computer to do a task like
drive a car but we don't have a computer
that makes decisions outside of that
task there is one thing that houses the
9000 series has a perfect operational
record excluding situations where
there's a hardware failure this is
actually correct computers will do
exactly what they've been asked to do so
any decisions that hal was making that
didn't make sense to the pilots it can
only be attributable to human error
during the journey the computer house
appears to be making mistakes this leads
of the astronauts to attempt to
deactivate how I know that you and Frank
were planning to disconnect me and I'm
afraid that's something I cannot allow
to happen it's actually very difficult
to design artificial intelligence that
can potentially be dangerous to humans
mostly because it's very difficult to
get machines to recognize when humans
are in danger the film is definitely not
an accurate depiction of the state of AI
in 2001 but I'd say this is a solid see
I can't believe I'm having this
conversation in my computer do you not
conversation with me her a world where
they're artificially intelligent
operating systems so the main character
in the movie gets an OS named Samantha
and they form a relationship I should
tell you that I'm not in a place to
commit to anything right now did I say I
wanted to commit to you I'm confused
Samantha is a very human character so
not just mimicking human emotion but
actually experiencing it I don't know
we're looking at those people I
fantasized that I was walking next to
you and that I had a body which makes
for a very interesting movie but is not
the way that computers behave today we
don't actually know how to make a
computer that lets things I want to
learn everything about everything I want
to eat it all up I want to discover
myself that's capable of growing beyond
what we asked of it eventually the
computers reached a point where they
were much more interested in each other
and much more interested in things that
were not relating to the humans who
created them what's called artificial
general intelligence which would be a
true sort of conscious AI we don't have
a reason to believe it's impossible but
we don't know how to get there and can
we even do it with a with a current
digital architecture or would we have to
switch to something that's closer to
what our brains are which is you know an
analog biological architecture but that
doesn't mean that we can't get there it
just means that we really don't know
when we'd be able to it's a very
interesting film it's not accurate and
it's a lot of interesting ideas about
how things could potentially evolve in
the future I'd say B - ex machina are
you building an AI I've already built
one a billionaire tech genius who builds
a humanoid AI robot and recruits a human
- to test it the real test is to show
you that she's a robot and then see if
you still feel she has consciousness so
we don't have a clear-cut definition of
what consciousness is the definition
that you know resonates the most with me
is to say that consciousness is the
experience of being yourself we don't
say that a thermometer knows what the
temperature is because there's no
internal experience
for a thermometer there is no reason to
believe that our our current computers
have any kind of internal experience
would we know it if we got it if we
built a very persuasive AI that could
interact as if it had an internal life
it's very unrealistic to say that the
first very human-like ki is going to fit
in a human-sized box current
supercomputers which are not capable of
producing consciousness fit in buildings
and are run by their own power plants
there is some some hand waving in the
movie about mythical quasi biological
processing architecture that they're
going to use to be able to achieve this
but again it's it's not based on
anything that's real and achievable
right now it's a very enjoyable movie
it's it's a movie that sort of explores
what does it mean to be human much more
than it explores what does it mean to be
AI and I would say if you were counting
on this movie to teach you about AI you
would not receive above it D - instead
of creating an artificial intelligence
he duplicated an existing one
transcendence there's an AI researcher
who is dying in order to preserve him
they upload his brain into a computer
that he's built I can't describe it it's
like my mind has been set free they hook
him up to the internet and suddenly he
has access to all this information he
never had he starts building things that
humans can't even comprehend we've made
a breakthrough with the nanotechnology
we can rebuild any material faster than
before this movie is full of lies
we can't scan a person's brain if we
could we'd have to take your brain apart
so don't don't try it on your own even
with the best technology you can't
overcome physical limitations it only
has so much storage space it only has so
much processing space there's only so
much power to run it you don't
automatically get this sort of runaway
increase in capability I think that
there is a point to be made about taking
the unknowable artificial entity and
hooking it up to the Internet and
letting it do whatever it wants
financial markets but it's unrealistic
even in its depiction of the threat
there the way the technology works is is
a solid F wargames it's basically about
an artificially intelligent computer
developed during the Cold War to sort of
simulate global thermonuclear war and
try to figure out under what scenarios
would you maximize survival of of
Americans a youthful hacker accidentally
accesses this computer and asset two to
play a game global thermonuclear war in
trying to win this game the computer
decides that the optimal strategy is to
actually start an immediate preemptive
strike against the Soviet Union
and launch a bunch of missiles so the
first takeaway is don't ever give a
computer the ability to launch your
nuclear missiles that's a terrible idea
this computer which is very very smart
in a very very inhuman way is doing
exactly what it was programmed to do and
it finds a solution and it goes to
execute on it and it doesn't understand
that it doesn't have all the context
that really the best way to win a global
thermonuclear war is to not ever start
one in the first place it's showing a
computer that's an antagonist but not a
malevolent one it just doesn't under
stand Oh a plus a plus I love working
when people make movies about computers
they're actually making movies about
people we like watching stories about
people or entities that are like us more
than we would like watching you know
this is the life of your toaster I think
as long as people view it as
entertainment and say that an artificial
intelligence monster is no more real
than a vampire or a zombie then it's
it's good clean fun it's actually a
really exciting time to be working in
artificial intelligence not because
we're building robots that have feelings
but because we're seeing a lot of really
exciting things in healthcare in energy
the the world of research in general has
been completely revolutionized there's
so much more good to AI than than bad
and that's sort of the vision of AI that
that I see moving forward
[Music]